I'll tell you something these Marines  keep rushing in like they're doing  they're gonna have their asses shot off  all the Marines I don't get the training  we do half these guys were civilians six  months ago  let's coach him up I'll show him how  team guys do it I'll live that unit on  the street no I can't do that we need  you on overwatch come on if I'm on the  street Marc I could miss the house is  the deadliest job here man you got some  sort of Savior complex I just want to  get the bad guys but if I can't see him  I can't shoot him like all these guys I  know your name they feel invincible with  you up there they're not they are if  they think they are don't you just keep  banging on the long gun what these dogs  sniff that was a college